des trucs russe depuis la libération de
Carson en novembre sont amassés sont
concentrés dans le don de base notamment
dans la ville de barmut tous les combats
sont particulièrement féroces barmouth
aujourd'hui c'est devenu l'épicentre
d'une des campagnes sans doute les plus
sanglantes de cette guerre et puis la
ville de soledar qui est située à
quelques kilomètres à peine c'est là où
il y a eu effectivement une percée de la
part des Russes qui a inquiété les
autorités ukrainiennes qui ont qui ont
commencé à communiquer là dessus alors
côté ukrainien on continue à dire que
les troupes ukrainiennes sont sur place
et continuent à se battre mais il s'agit
du groupe Wagner pas seulement de
l'armée régulière ou des mobilisés
russes là-bas les combats sont donc plus
offensifs plus violents encore et
Solidar c'est un endroit qui est très
stratégique puisqu'il y a beaucoup de
tunnels souterrains sous la ville lié à
l'extraction de sel alors voilà là-bas
on nous rapporte les civils qui ont été
évacuées par les darmes automatiques
entendues de deux tirs de chars de
combat qui sont vraiment
particulièrement féroces et tient bon
par contre c'est devenu un cri de
ralliement ici en Ukraine puisque les
Ukrainiens sont vraiment déterminés à se
battre jusqu'au bout à un moment où et
bien avec la promesse de livraison de
plus d'armes occidentales encore et bien
les Ukrainiens veulent tenir à tout prix
mais il faut dire que côté russe
également il y a une volonté de ne pas
lâcher après plusieurs mois sans
victoire majeures dans cette zone donc
la situation reste extrêmement tendue et
les heures les jours qui viennent vont
sans doute être décisifs après cette
première percée et puis il faut dire que
sur les 100 000 habitants de la ville de
barmouth il ne reste que 7000 personnes
que la plupart des civils évacuent car
la situation continue vraiment à se
dégrader pour les ukra